[Music]  day four of the st. Louis rapid enlist  history-making events the world of check  it was on the place where the best  players in the world were determined to  showcase their lightning-fast skills  under unrelenting pressure tournament  leader Levon Aronian continued his great  run and was able to extend his lead  against his main rival by the end of the  round but the day belongs to surging  Sergei Kuryakin  who swore to simply eight out of nine  and serve notice that the world bliss  champion was ready to fight for first is  the last half lit with nine rounds of  are stopping action final round play for  all the marbles coming up now  [Music]